[Musique]
bonjour à tous madame monsieur goût jour
invité de sao qu'a dit ce matin muriel
jean baptiste bonjour bonjour vous êtes
la secrétaire générale de la fcpe la
fédération des conseils de parents
d'élèves
quels mots pourraient caractériser cette
rentrée scolaire selon vous alors le mot
qui caractérise cette année c'est des
gilles ans vigilant sur tous les fronts
pour que nos élèves puissent étudier
dans de bonnes conditions ce qui marque
cette rentrée ce sont donc les réformes
d'abord chez les petits l'école
obligatoire à partir de 3 ans bien sûr
oui tout à fait pour vous parents
d'élèves
c'est quelque chose de positif oui c'est
quelque chose de très positif mais il
faut qu'on donne les moyens aux
personnels pédagogiques d'accueillir ses
élèves dans de bonnes conditions
c'est ce n'est pas encore le cas dans
les écoles où vous est implanté et ceux
qui vous conduit remonte du terrain ce
n'est pas encore le cas il ya toujours
des axes d'amélioration donc c'est pour
ça qu'on le dit donc il faut qu'on soit
vigilant sur les conditions d'accueil de
ses enfants
mais c'est vrai que la majorité des
écoles de martinique accueille déjà ses
enfants donc là il faut faire encore
faire plus attention à l'accueil de ces
enfants
autre réforme celle des lycées et celle
du bac
là vous êtes un peu plus sceptique quand
même c'est à dire on est nous à la fcpe
on est pauvre on était pour la réforme
du bac mais pas dans ces conditions que
cette réforme a été faite rapidement
donc on a senti qu'ils avaient pas
vraiment de concertation donc on aurait
souhaité que cette réforme soit mis en
place en 2020
qu'est ce qui vous gêne exactement c'est
quoi le problème pour vous au niveau de
cette réforme
alors ce qui nous gêne principalement
c'est le fait de de demander aux élèves
de seconde d'avoir une logique de
métiers on sait bien que les élèves de
seconde n'ont pas encore cette logique
de métiers et que on a un élève son
avenir c'est à six mois a tout au plus
un ton qu'on lui demande de faire un
choix qui sera qui va sceller son avenir
dès la seconde aussi bien que les élèves
vont faire des choix différents
au cours de leur scolarité
et en fonction de leur rencontre c'est
ça au même même après le bac il ya du il
ya 10 et une savent pas encore ce qu'ils
vont faire même en ayant choisi une
filière universitaire ils peuvent
toujours changer c'est ça il s'en sort
ça vous inquiète
ça nous inquiète parce qu'il faut
informer et beaucoup les parents pour
qu'ils puissent guider au mieux leurs
enfants dans leurs choix des spécialités
on vous savait qu'ils allaient neuf
spécialités cette année il ya un tronc
commun en première et ensuite les élèves
ont le choix entre neuf spécialités
alors je vais vous donner quelques unes
des spécialités à littérature
mathématiques écologie etc
ça passe obligatoirement dans le même
établissement et ses salles aussi pour
vous le problème c'est à dire c'est
cette logique de réseau des
établissements et ça ça pose problème
donc ça se passe ça se passe pas
forcément dans les mêmes établissements
parce que tous les établissements n'ont
pas les professeurs le personnel pour
faire toutes les spécialités
donc c'est vrai ya une logique de réseau
qui a été mis en place
donc on aura des spécialités dont par
exemple d'apprendre lycéens qu'ajoie et
sa cage ou deux lefranc roi donc les
élèves devront choisir les spécialités
en fonction de l'eau dans leur projet
professionnel
une problématique ont à relever c'est
que les c'est vrai que les spécialités
ont été soumis en général dans le cours
d après midi notamment le vendredi les
spécialités n'étant pas dispensés dans
les mêmes établissements il faut que les
élèves puissent se déplacer vers ces
d'établissement l'a donc quid du
transport donc comment les élèves vaut
faire pour se déplacer rapidement vers
le rétablissement d'un choeur boulot
spécialité les spécialités qu'ils ont
choisis donc nous demandons qui est
quand même une réflexion poussée pour le
transport de ces élèves là et nous
souhaitons que c'est que c'est ce
transport soins gratuits soit mise à
disposition qui habille un service de
bus met à disposition des élèves si
c'est pour ça c'est justement ça ça vous
avez l'impression que ça risque de
générer des coûts supplémentaires aux
familles centristes généré des coûts
supplémentaires aux familles mais ça
risque aussi étant donné que
les élèves ne pourront pas choisir les
spécialités qui souhaitent ya certains
parents qui ont qui ont mis long qui ont
laissé les enfants dans le même lycée
parce que ça y avait un coût
supplémentaire donc certains élèves
n'ont pas forcément les spécialités
qu'ils demandent
cette année ça crée des inégalités sacré
certainement des zigs et des inégalités
et nous demandons à ce que les parents
soient informés de cette situation là
qu'ils soient conscients des choix de
leurs enfants parce qu'il faut savoir
que ça va déterminer la suite de leurs
études
il faut faire attention au choix de ses
spécialités pour qu'on puisse être
conformes je dirais pour qu'on puisse
accéder à sa assas à ses études
supérieures aux études supérieures
choisi autre point qui vous préoccupe
on reste toujours dans le domaine du
transport c'est le transport scolaire
notamment le respect des des arts
expliqué nous un peu parce que en
parlant avec vous on a compris que
certains élèves pouvaient alors se
réveiller trop tôt bien arrivé trop tôt
en place expliqué nous alors on est de
plus on est depuis des années très
vigilent au niveau de la fcpe au niveau
du respect ddd circuit parce qu'il faut
savoir quand les ont commises et les pas
exprès tôt à l'école
sa venue qui se sont réveillées plus tôt
donc ça veut dire qu'au cours de l'inde
la journée ils seront fatigués des
élèves se réveille parfois même à 4
heures du matin à ces quatre heures du
matin donc nous on nous souhaitons qu'il
y ait un respect des bains du marché des
circuits des moins de transport curité
édité et édictées dans le marché mais
aussi la sécurité des enfants au niveau
des bus au niveau aussi des
comportements des chauffeurs donc c'est
c'est le maître mot c'est vigilance jour
d'hui nous n'avons pas encore de de
remontée significative on est le jour
d'après on va dire donc c'est vrai que
samedi nous avons les réunions avec nos
adhérents et on aura un certain nombre
de retours donc mais on est vigilant
depuis des années sur ces problématiques
de transport c'est très important pour
l'attention des élèves pour la réussite
des élèves
pour la réussite des élèves
l'encadrement aussi savent où il ya un
problème au niveau de l'encadrement des
élèves
il n'y a pas assez de surveillants selon
vous alors y'a peut-être pas assez de
survire mais on on voudrait que les
surveillants bénéficient d'une formation
continue c'est à dire nos adolescents
évolue il faut que les formations qu'on
dispense aux surveillants soient adaptés
à anneaux à l'évolution des de nos
adolescents la spoiler pour la matière
notamment de sécurité et ainsi de
sécurité des nouvelles technologies des
portables également bien sûr et puis au
niveau des addictions aussi qui est
quand même une écoute les adolescents
des besoins des attentes qui ont évolué
au fil du temps donc il faut que nous
adultes nous soyons à l'écouté nous
soyons formés pour pouvoir les
accompagner au mieux pour la réussite de
notre de leur scolarité puisque ce qui
nous intéresse à épices direct ou par un
plus haut à lens c'est la réussite de
nos enfants quand comme quand vous voyez
par exemple que les contrats aidés ne
seront pas renouvelés en 2020 est ce que
cela vous attire au jeu ce que cela vous
interpelle ça nous interpelle donc il
faut alors je c'est un mot que je vais
répéter cette vigilance c'est d'avoir
les contacts permanents avec les
institutionnels pour expliquer nos
doléances et pour faire un retour
d'expérience pour faire une évaluation
sur cette situation
autre point de la réforme on reste sur
les on parle de rien su plus tôt sur les
lycées c'est le bac et le contrôle
continu
oui là aussi vous
vous posez des questions non on est
toujours dans l'information des départs
en sachant que à partir de là de la
première on a trois spécialités mans son
terminal ont là il ya une spécialité
qu'on abandonne donc il faut faire le
bon choix parce qu'on a des spécialités
qui sont alors vous avez un volume
horaire de 12 heures en première
le volume horaire ne diminue pas en
terminale mais vous avez à ce moment là
l'élève a droit à deux spécialités
donc on est toujours la réforme est là
il est dépassé donc il faut qu'on soit
accompagné au cours de cette réforme il
faut que surtout les parents soient
informés
vous êtes des tenants et aboutissants de
cette réforme pour mieux accompagner
leurs enfants
parlons maintenant de l'accueil dix
enfants d' en situation de handicap
l'ia l'école inclusive
on va dans le bon sens selon vous bien
sûr ces enfants méritent d'être
scolarisés le tout c'est que tout le
monde soit informé et qui a une
communication entre eux entre tout le
monde que tout le monde bénéficie du
même niveau d'information et c'est ce
qui manque des fois il faut que le
personnel pédagogique est des
informations mais que le personnel
d'animation personnel qui accompagnent
les et les élèves en dehors des heures
de classe soit informé mais aussi que
les enfants qui vont côtoyer ces
enfants-là et un minimum d'informations
parce que nous avons les enfants sont
bienveillants il suffit de les de les
informer de la situation de l'autre
petits camarades pour qu'ils puissent
les accueillir à bras ouverts
donc c'est mes enfants méritent d'être
scolarisés tu sais pas tout ce laps de
survie doit passer par une bonne
communication mais s'il ya les moyens
mais des moyens sont suffisants bon la
communication n'a pas forcément besoin
d'avoir des moyens supplémentaires mais
l'encadrement oui bien sûr mais il faut
communiquer la communication passe par
la main par vous comme vous et moi ce
matin nous nous parlons il faut parler
et ça c'est important
mais les encadrants pour les enfants en
situation dont en situation de handicap
est ce que c'est en quatre ans là sont
assez son sens on a ces boissons sont
suffisants alors c'est vrai que
l'encadrement des fois ce fait
tardivement pour ces enfants là donc
l'idée il faut que les enfants soient
suivies plus tôt
donc les parents soient informés de
l'itinéraire à suivre pour pouvoir
donner à leurs enfants les moyens pour
réussir donc c'est vrai qu'il ya le
recteur nous a précisé qu il y aura d d
d éléments qui vont être mis en place
des informations qui vont être mis en
place pour pour aider au mieux les les
parents et non au niveau de la cpe on
communique beaucoup sur cette
problématique là alors nous allons
parler maintenant de vos actions vous
avez lancé votre campagne de dépistage
visuel gratuite alors pourquoi c'est
nécessaire ce type de campagne est
vraiment nécessaire aujourd'hui
alors c'est notre quatorzième édition et
ses intérêts nous faisons cela chaque
année depuis 14 ans puisque c'est un
élément important dans la réussite de
nos enfants
un enfant qui ne voient pas huillet ne
peut pas entrer dans les apprentissages
donc va'a va avoir un retard et va
développer un manque d'attention et va
être indisciplinés au niveau de la
classe très important on sensibilise
depuis 14 ans les parents dernière
question en rapidement ce samedi vous
lancez vos ateliers d'information des
parents et de vos adhérents
bien sûr alors le samedi 7 septembre à
edouard glissant au collège edouard
glissant au lamentin de 14h30 à 17h30
nous accueillons nos adhérents sur
différentes thématiques pour qu'ils
puissent mieux commencer l'année avoir
les bonnes informations
mais aux yeux de jean baptiste je vous
remercie bonne journée l écoute de nos
programmes
merci et merci à la librairie qu'on
retrouve demain